when you calculated they're right we
have shifted in to a new way of
measuring angles a new way of measuring
angles now already going to great
lengths to explain radians on units the
way degrees are units but for the
purposes of your calculator like you are
putting in different numbers and you've
got the same answer so for instance we
know by now what's sine of 90 degrees is
sine of 90 of course is this one that's
the sine of 90 degrees is one right
answer the question nothing in your head
okay but but we're just going to say
well if I'm not talking it radians right
this is us I wouldn't say sine 90
degrees I would say sine of pi on two
and I still wanted to give me the same
thing
the given problem is plan - is 90
degrees right or 90 rather pi/2 is well
pi is 3.14 so quite a to be one point
five seven and so on okay so I need to
go tell my calculator hey I really made
a right angle that's why I really
referred to so therefore you go to your
calculator and you go shift and on the
top right hand corner you've got that I
wouldn't set up on do that and you can
see at least on my calculator most of
you aren't sharing this calculator on
the second row it says this
so at the moment there is a tiny little
box on the top of your display which
says armed it's a boxing scissors deep
in at four degrees you need to use four
and you will see that box changing to
our little box it says an R in it and
now you're in this mode and to check
that you're in that mode type inside and
you've got your brightness de cos PI
divided by 2 and when you end the
brackets it should faithfully give you
back y know at least if your calculator
is worth the money you pay for if not so
please pay attention to what kind of
angle you're supplying into your
calculator when it's relevant like
question four and five is when it
appears and that way you won't get yes
okay yes okay short oh and it's a great
question it's such a great question let
me ask all of you to pause for a minute
so I can answer it that's very practical
the question was about the merger
calculator is it and in an exam context
like watching you do what happens if you
forget but let me say two things number
one we're going to talk about conversion
a lot in this exercise that's because
like I said you need to bridge from this
world over into this one things do
behave a little bit different you just
have to get used to that okay when you
see a question in the HSC
it will either be in degrees or in
radians okay it kind of depends on the
context now jinsoon was alluded to this
yesterday when we're doing geometry like
a straight line through that kind of
thing frequently we will be talking in
degrees like if you're in a two unit
exam and you have to solve like a
various question to treat various
question
it will probably integrate and that's
because sailors don't tend to say yes by
on through to starboard like okay
so therefore they're in degrees land
right you won't find a compass in the
world that measures in in radians
relieved degrees so if you're in degrees
don't change it don't change the
question into radians so your calculator
can deal with it just deal with the
question of degrees and change your
calculator by the same token when you
are in circles and when you're dealing
with most Street functions and certainly
when you are dealing in calculus you
will find everything supply to you in
radians right so we're used to saying
okay I'll draw my graph from dr. 3cc
right nostril through 16 what we mean is
not to 360 degrees you'll see that the
increasingly written like this please go
from naught to 2pi okay what that's what
they mean go that same amount wonderful
period of finance right if your question
is in radians
though you will become quite good at
converting please do not convert the
whole point is that in a question which
is Delta great
gradients are more elegant and more easy
to deal with so don't go away from them
don't and please please don't like solve
the question Midway and then say okay
I'm now gonna change me fries into
radians like that's that's like the
easiest way to get yourself confused now
all that said I want you to go back to
your calculator put it in to put it into
degrees back into degrees and then what
I want you to do is repeat this
calculation that I asked you to do OK
repeat this side pile - ok now when you
do it what you should get supplied with
is a very confusing number it's also a
very small number why is this number so
small
very good I need a degrees mode I read
the poem to is just a number I was just
saying for its three three point one
four divided by two so it's it's
interpreting you as saying this now
that's a really tiny number it's a tiny
do have a no whatever measures in a
that's one that's why inside is
something like 0.02 something like that
now this is just a signal to say wait
something is gone horribly wrong okay
I'm in the wrong bird don't just look at
anything all that's that's garbage
right it's not garbage it's a betting
boat right there there is one point five
seven degrees okay so this is to
interpret what your calculators painting
back to you if you are using this in
like a signing request or a cosine
normal finding the area of triangle
you'll find everything is like fifty
times too small okay there is a reason
for that
okay so the first thing is just if your
question is in one thing or another
change your catheter to that mode I know
some students who are on there like this
they actually in you knew something to
come is ready you bring multiple
calculators into the exam and then they
say okay I have a degrees calculator and
I have a radians calculator on your to
calculate is on your desk and you put
the ratings one on the right because
it's four right yeah now that that's all
way of doing it to be honest I kind of
like I grew up in an age where we just
we just risked it with one calculator to
these in so just just let me change like
the first thing when you're going
through reading time is you look at
whether you're a degrees or radians and
then when you encounter the questions